one they fund 12 times as much 12
billion dollars a year
compared to the government of nutrition
science that shows candy is great for
weight loss for kids
and the soda is not linked to obesity
which is just nonsense right
they co-op professional societies like
the american heart association
the academy of nutrition dietetics and
fund
their organizations the nutrition
organization gets 40
of their funding from the food industry
and in their annual conference
you're not allowed to take pictures in
the exhibit hall because they don't want
people to see all the junk food that
they're promoting
it's terrifying to me because we're
threatening our future generation we're
threatening our global economic
competitiveness
uh we're threatening our ability to
actually have good national security
because 70
of their recruits for the military are
rejected because they're unfit to fight
it's a
a national security threat that the
generals and admirals have written
a report saying unhealthy and unprepared
i mean just from just from the war in
iraq and afghanistan
there were 70 plus percent more
evacuations
for obesity-rated related injuries than
for war injuries
think about that incredible that
actually almost doesn't sound it doesn't
sound possible and then i just talked to
a woman who works
at the top level in the department of
defense a couple of days ago she said
on on the military bases that are just
loaded with fast food restaurants
the combat troops are not
combat ready because they become so
unfit
so that's well how do you get from
knowing that this stuff ain't right to
having all these fast food joints on
the combat bases well just like they
have fast food in schools they have
mcdonald's monday and taco bell tuesday
and wendy's wednesday
80 of contracts of the schools have
contracts with soda companies
uh you know these companies are very
smart and deliberate so
while there may not have been bad
intentions to start there is a lot of
bad behavior now they they have a
massive way of controlling the narrative
about
food and confusing consumers confusing
scientists and confusing politicians
one they fund 12 times as much 12
billion dollars a year
compared to the government of nutrition
science that shows candy is great for
weight loss for kids
and that soda is not linked to obesity
which is just nonsense right
they co-op professional societies like
the american heart association
the academy of nutrition dietetics and
fund
their organizations the nutrition
organization gets 40
of their funding from the food industry
and in their annual conference
you're not allowed to take pictures in
the exhibit hall because they don't want
people to see all the junk food that
they're promoting
right they fund the american heart
association which allows them to say
tricks
are a heart-healthy food because it's
low in fat i mean it's it's frightening
they create
front groups four companies spend half a
billion dollars
on front groups to confuse consumers
saying
that for example uh that pesticides and
high fructose corn syrup and trans fats
and smoking are not bad for you like the
american council on science and health
they spent 30 million dollars fighting
gmo labeling in california
when they won that battle they fund
social groups like the naacp and
hispanic federation so they co-opt
the very groups that are most affected
by these conditions like diabetes and
obesity
so they will oppose things like soda
taxes they were the one of the biggest
opposition groups to the big gulp
uh recommendations from michael
bloomberg which i think was an
ill-advised idea but still they were
opposing it right
because they were funded by these groups
they fund
nutritionists and dietitians to go on
social media
saying we shouldn't have soda taxes or
that soda's okay
i mean it's it's just insidious and then
they fund the political process
so just on one bill the gmo labeling
bill
which is was euphemistically called the
dark act denying americans the right to
know
they spent 192 million dollars in one
year on one bill
they spent half a billion dollars on the
farm bill which is
governing most of our food programs like
food stamps they fund feeding america
which is a
hunger group which is great a hunger
advocacy group to make sure we deal with
hunger in america
on the board of that group our high
level
executives from the food industry which
is why they oppose
restricting food stamps for soda
or other junk food right so now
government is paying
seven billion dollars a year the single
biggest light item for food stamps for
soda for the poor
that's 30 billion servings and they get
sicker than back to the medicare
problems
and the true cost of food is not in the
price we pay at the checkout counter
so you buy a can of soda well let's look
at what happens to the corn record i'm
off the soda
good i just feel that i have to tell you
that i haven't had a regular soda and
god knows how long
so so here's here's just absolutely club
is good
here's how the the the the sort of
connectivity works in corn so yeah
government funds the subsidies that
support corn production
these mono crops that are heavy use of
fertilizers
pesticides herbicides
that corn production itself destroys the
soil
causes release of carbon into the
atmosphere soil
carbon is a third of all the carbon in
the atmosphere from the wavy farm
and contributing to climate change it it
actually
destroys the ecosystem pollinators and
bees are killed who's paying for that
right
it destroys the rivers lakes and oceans
as i mentioned and creates dead zones
because of the fertilizer runoff
then the food that's produced is the raw
materials for junk food and for soda
then we pay for that to be
given at the tune of about 75 billion
dollars a year to the poor
in food stamp products 75 of that is
junk food seven
ten percent of soda so they eat that and
then we pay for medicare medicaid
on the back end when they have diabetes
and obesity related
illnesses and so we're not paying for
the economic of the the
impact on our environment and climate
where we're
paying for it literally four times and
that price is not in the can of coke it
should be maybe a hundred dollars for
canada coke when you
include all those costs right okay you
gave me a lot there
yeah sorry first i have to jump back for
a second you you're calling it danone i
always thought it was dannon
yeah in america standing in europe it's
called okay now
all right all right that was sticking
with me this whole time so i'm glad we
got yeah
i got it you know got the important
thing out of the way you say tomato i
say tomato
okay so you did grow up in spain now
right now now
it's a european company so that's how
they say it okay fair enough uh
that actually is perfect segue to my
next question which is how much of this
is uniquely an american problem oh my
god
yes we have basically created the worst
diet in the world
and are exporting it to every country on
the planet and what's frightening to me
is you know i was in china in 1984.
there was no obesity
there was no diabetes now they
have a hundred plus million diabetics in
china
it's it's the number one country in the
world with diabetics
they're exactly that's probably just a
numbers game though right just because
the amount of votes
no it used to be one in 50. oh okay so
now it's one in ten
okay so per yeah it's one in ten yeah
india is number two
and in the middle east it's you know one
in four have diabetes
uh in the developing world eighty
percent of the diabetics
and uh and obesity related issues and
chronic disease are in the developing
world
eighty percent so uh in countries like
africa in india and china junk food fast
food is
aspirational if you want to take your
date out in america for a good time
you don't take her to mcdonald's but
that's what they do
in the developing world is a premium
brand
mcdonald's is a premium band domino's is
a premium brand my brother-in-law was
living in el salvador doing some work
some research work down there
and we went down there and basically you
know i saw
wendy's and there was a lot of wendy's i
think it was wednesday wendy's
and a couple other chain things and
those were the night that's where
everyone wanted to go because that was
sort of thought of as the nice stuff
yeah which is a very backwards
no thank god for you and these kinds of
shows because this kind of conversation
wouldn't happen on traditional tv
i was watching good morning america the
other day and i was in a green room
about to go on a show and i don't
watch tv and there was a whole segment
where they gave free wendy's
breakfast burgers or whatever the junk
they'd give them to the entire audience
and then they were talking about these
great wendy's breakfast things
and they were eating the hosts were
eating them right they had a big ad
after
and it's like you know the host would
never eat that stuff normally
no they wouldn't but but the media is
co-opted who funds the media and
advertising today
big pharma and food big food if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell